you know my next guest as the very funny
doctors from the hit series scrubs now
they have a podcast called fake doctors
real friends where they break down the
good the bad and the hilariously
embarrassing moments of every single
scrubs episode which we all want to know
about I'm talking about Zach Braff and
Donald Faison hey what's up y'all what
is good for doing the show I really
really appreciate it I know it's an
awkward thing we tried to make it look
like my show like not a real background
is that like a virtual background no
dude they can't this is my formal living
room and they it's gone and they
literally put a whole set up behind me
Donald are you in a closet I am in my
closet this is where I escape reality I
escaped the wife I escaped the kids and
this is also where we do the podcast it
is funny and this like pandemic time to
find especially we were in like a cabin
in Montana now I'm in LA but we're in a
cabin Montana is so small and there's
like nowhere to go and literally would
end up in a bathroom weird we started we
started recording the podcast and Donald
needed to find a place that was like
good for sound and sir barber this
closet and then he realized that his
kids didn't want to come in there and
his wife would leave him alone and so
now I think his whole family thinks he
makes the podcast like every day
absolutely absolutely absolutely
sometimes I doodle because y'all are
actual like real friends and that's why
I like your podcast like fake doctors
you played on on the TV show but he
reminds like has it been hard like I
know we're all with our family it's nice
to have it family time but I miss
friends like deal
do y'all miss each other like hanging
out I miss him tremendously so much
that's what started we were gonna do
this podcast before quarantine and and
because we were planning on doing it and
then when quarantine happened it became
a thing where Donald I who we can't see
each other so like twice a week when we
record we have like an hour and a half
to just laugh and tell stories and catch
up and you know we talk about the show
we talked about episodes of the show
that's sort of like the structure of the
show but then we go off on all these
tangents and it's actually given us a
formal structure
like check in twice a week and tell
stories I might crack up and it's it's
like therapy because you know we're all
lonesome and and we're just cracking up
yeah it's great it's great to be able to
talk to your best friend for an hour and
a half away from the kids in silence for
you know twice a week it's wonderful
okay speaking up your wife know that she
wants that hour to talk to her girls
okay oh no I know
trust me I know she complains about it
all the time she's like you know I wish
I had a podcast you know Jessica
Simpson's her best friend I go why don't
you do a podcast with Jessica Simpson
you can have your own time hilarious you
could merger sometimes
okay frontline workers are really saving
us these days and this is something I
actually never knew y'all actually shot
that at a real hospital I think that was
a set the whole time no we took over an
enormous Hospital and we couldn't
believe it either
and everything was built into it we
would there was four floors well then
there was the basement and the roof so
technically six because we used all of
it and they were tied and our dressing
rooms were on one floor all the
production office were another floor and
they would film every single corner of
the place even the sets like our
apartment that warrant the hospital they
built into the hospital kind of like
your set yeah so it was amazing we kind
of had our own campus we lived in an
abandoned hospital for eight and a half
years yeah it was really weird though
for the first couple of seasons you know
I guess the hospital had just recently
become abandoned and people would just
straggling off the street you asking for
you know asking for medicine and we were
like sorry this isn't a real hospital
and they look around and see everyone in
costume in scrubs and nurses what are
you talking about at the entrance and a
huge science that this is not a working
Hospital do not come here for emergency
care yeah Wow and how I would have felt
horrible about that like turning people
who are
miles down that way like trust me you
don't want me to do anything
Oh Donald since you've been isolated
from each other for a while what do you
miss doing the most together
I miss dinners you know what I mean
because we get a chance to talk a lot I
miss dinners and drinking wine together
and you know laughing over a meal
I missed that the most I want to be
friends with you as well welcome to the
only reason down and I wanted to come on
your show other than to plug our podcast
was to hope that maybe you would be our
friend and come to dinner with us when
this is all over if you are welcome
anytime
I am like literally like I think we're
all so excited to god I mean a dinner
party you're going out to restaurant
anything like other than what's been
happening like I am down you get a zoom
call even if it's like even if it's for
work or something and you see new people
you like and then you start telling
stories that are really not good stories
but it's just what's happening and then
they go entertained by them and I'm like
why I'm entertained about this is
another level of sad and you find
yourself looking in people's backgrounds
like I'm like looking like a book is
that Meyers and I actually recognized
one of the books not realizing he was
putting it up there to be funny that
they're dumb books to him and I was like
oh I've seen that little miniseries and
he was like oh yeah I was gonna say oh
that's a Gibson on the wall that was the
first thing I recognized I was like I'm
a Gibson yeah both of them I would love
a it are poorly that's the best part of
my show that we have guitars on walls
but I play poorly subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going